hello this is toast in Tampa an
architect at IBM for data and analytics
in the cloud and I'm going to talk to
you about data leaks in the cloud the
center of a data leak in a cloud is the
data persistency itself so we talked
about persistency of data and the data
itself in the cloud data Lake is
persisted in object storage but we don't
just persist the data itself we also
persist information about the data which
is on one side information about indexes
so we need to index the data so that we
can make use of this data in the cloud
data like efficiently and we also need
to store metadata about the data in a
catalog
so this is our persistency of the data
leak now the question is how do we get
this data into the data leak so there
are different types of data that we can
ingest so we need to talk about
ingestion of data and we can have the
situation that some of your data is
already persisted in databases so these
can be relational databases can also be
other operational databases no sequel
databases and so on and we get this data
into a data Lake actually why are two
fundamental mechanisms one is basically
an ETL which stands for extract
transform load and this is done in a
batch fashion and the typical mechanism
to do ETL is using sequel and since we
are talking about cloud data leak so
this is sequel as a service now but
there's also an addition and you combine
those things the mechanism of
replication which is basically more to
change feed so after you may have batch
etl the initial data set we talked about
how do you replicate all of the changes
that coming in after this initial magic
tale next we may have data that does not
persist it yet at all which is generated
as we are speaking here for instance
from devices so we may have things like
devices out there IOT devices driving
cars and alike and they are actually
producing a lot of IOT messages all the
time continuously and they need to
basically also land it and streamed in
to the data lake so here we're talking
about a streaming mechanism and in a
very similar manner we are taught we
have data that is originated from
applications that are running in the
cloud or services that are used by your
applications they are all producing logs
and that's very valuable information
especially if you're talking about
operational optimizations and gaining
business insights of your user behavior
and these kind of things this is very
important data that we need to get hold
of so talk about logs
it is also needs a streaming mechanism
to basically get streamed and stored in
object storage and finally you may have
to situation that you do already have
data sitting around in local disks all
right you may have local disks maybe on
your own on your own machine you may
have even added a local data like a
classical data Lake not in the cloud
often typically these are Hadoop
clusters that you have on-premise in
your enterprise or it can be as simple
as you find it very frequently just NFS
shares that are used
in your team in your enterprise to store
a certain data and if you want to
basically get them to data link you also
need a mechanism and it's basically an
upload mechanism so the data Lake needs
to provide you an efficient mechanism to
upload data from ground on premises to
the cloud into the object storage now
the next thing we need to do when it
went to data is here we need to process
it you need to process the data
especially this is especially important
if we're talking about data that hasn't
gone through an initial processing
like for instance device data
application yet this is pretty raw data
that has very raw format that is very
volatile that has very different
structures changing schema and sometimes
it doesn't have a real structure this
kind can be binary data let's say images
that are being taken by devices cameras
and you need to extract features from
that so we're talking about feature
extraction from this date on this data
but even if you have no already
structure extracted it might still need
a lot of cleansing you may have two
basic normalize it to certain units you
may have to roll it up to a certain time
boundaries get rid of null values and
these kind of things so there's a lot of
things that you need to do about
transformation you need to transform the
data once you have transformed the data
basically you know I'll have the data
that you potentially now can use for
other analytics but one an additional
thing is advisable that you should do
with this data you could basically
create indexes if you index this data so
that we know more about the data and can
do proficient performance analytics and
finally you also should basically
leverage effect that we have a CAD not
gonna need to leverage it and you need
to tell us they do detect Eller
did a leg about this by cataloging this
data so there are multiple steps and of
me talking about the pipeline of data
transformations that need to be done
here now the question is what do we use
here and they actually two processes to
actually two mechanisms to services or
types of services that are especially
suited for this type of processing one
is functioning as a service and the
other one is sequel as a service again
so but sequel and function is a service
you can do this whole range of things
here you can basically create indexes
through secret idiotic and create tables
for sweet equity the else you can
transform data when you can use
functions with custom libraries and
custom code to do feature extractions
from the format of the data that you
need to process once we have gone
through this pipeline the question is
what's next now right so we have
prepared we have processed all of this
data and we have properly cataloged it
so we know what data we have now it
comes to the point that we really
harvesting all of this work by basically
generating insights
so generating insights is on one side
the whole group of data business
intelligence which consists of things
like doing reporting or creating
dashboards and that's what's typically
often referred to SBI and one option
that is possible now is to simply
directly do basically bi against this
data and a data like but actually it
turns out that is especially useful or
an option for batch ETL options like
creating reports in a batch fashion
because when it comes to more
interactive requirements you need
basically sitting in front of the screen
and you need to refresh it in sub-second
let's say dashboard here there is
actually another very important
mechanism that is very well-established
and that is part of this overall data
ecosystem
and this is a data warehouse so data
warehouse or a database may be a more
general is highly optimized and has a
lot of mechanisms for giving you low
latency and also guaranteed response
times for your queries so the question
is how do we do that now we obviously
need to get move this data one step
further after it has gone through all of
the data preparation in the data Lake
with an ETL again and it happens to be
again that sequel as a service is the
use of mechanism because it's a service
that we know on the cloud we already use
it to ETL data in to the data like now
we can also use a detail data out of
this data like into a data warehouse so
that it's now in this I would say more
traditional established stack of doing
bi that can be used by Europeans
reporting tools dashboarding tools
to do interactive bi
with sort of performance and response
time SaaS right so that's one end to end
flow now but very obviously insights is
more than just doing reporting in - body
alright so there's a whole domain of
tools and frameworks out there for more
advanced types of analytics such as
machine learning or simply using data
science data science tools and framework
that now basically can do also analytics
and basically do AI artificial
intelligence against the data that we've
prepared here in a catalog and machine
learning tools and data science tools
basically they all have very strong
support for accessing data in an object
storage so that's why this is a good fit
to basically let them connect directly
here to this data lake now that's now
the end-to-end pros is basically getting
from your data with a help of a data
Lake into insights one of the big
problems that is there today is for
people who do that to prove and explain
how they got to this insight how can you
trust this inside
how can you reproduce this inside so one
of the key things that needs to be part
of this picture is data governance so
data governance
in this context has two main things that
we need to take care of one is we need
to be able to trick the lineage of data
right because we have seen the data is
traveling from different sources through
preparation into some insight and form
of a report and you need to be able
always to track back where did this
report come from why is it looking like
this what's the data that basically
produced it and the other things is you
need to be able that we can enforce what
the data lik actually need to be able to
enforce policies governance policies who
is able to access what who is able to
see personal information and can I
access that directly or only an
anonymized and mask formed so these are
all governance rules and they are
governance services available also in
the cloud that basically data lake needs
to apply and basically also use in order
to track all of this so we are almost
done with this overall data Lake
introduction there's one more thing that
I want to highlight and this is since we
are talking about in the cloud how can I
deploy my entire pipeline of traveling
data traveling through this whole
infrastructure how can i aughtta mate
that and here basically functioning as a
service plays a special role because
function as a service has a lot of
mechanisms that can it I can use to
schedule and automate things like for
instance a batch ETL step all like
basically generating a report so this is
the final thing that we need in our data
Lake in order to automate and
operationalize eventually my entire data
and analytics using the data Lake thank
you very much
you